the u.s is watching moscow closely in
2020.
two weeks before the election the fbi
indicted six russians on charges of
engaging in cyber attacks on the 2018
winter olympics and the 2017 french
election
no country has weaponized its cyber
capabilities
as maliciously and irresponsibly as
russia
meanwhile microsoft reported that a
russian hacker group attacked hundreds
of political organizations and campaigns
and a facebook investigation discovered
a network of russian trolls that paid
americans
to write for a fake news site u.s
authorities have been cracking down to
prevent what happened during the 2016
u.s presidential election
russia is behind the hacks that have
brought democratic party and clinton
campaign emails into the public eye the
growing
furor over moscow's use of social media
to influence
the 2016 presidential election
the u.s accused russia of hacking and
trolling attempts aimed at hurting the
democratic candidate in 2016.
moscow has denied any interference in
the u.s elections
u.s officials experts at social media
companies
and researchers at cyber security firms
all say that
russia remains a very active and very
serious threat
one that everybody's very much on the
lookout for
even after election day while officials
and cyber security experts say they
haven't found as much activity from
russia
and as we saw in the 2016 they say
russian hackers and trolls have expanded
their toolkit and have become
much more sophisticated and harder to
detect
in 2016 russian trolls created fake
accounts and posted memes that attacked
hillary clinton
they also bought advertisements on
facebook and organized events including
ones that drew support for donald trump
this year the trolls tried something
different they set up a network of
accounts and pages that were largely
linked to a website called peacedata.net
but to anyone who knows russian the
website's name hinted at its trolling
origin
when you say p's data quickly it sounds
like a russian obscenity
piece data tried to look like a credible
news outlet and trick people into
then relying on that as their dues after
a tip from the fbi
facebook said it discovered that peace
data was run by people linked to a
russian troll factory called the
internet research agency
it had been accused by u.s authorities
of designing a social media campaign to
provoke political and social discord
what we found was a website that was
entirely run by
fake personas ben nemo runs
investigations at grafica
a research firm that contracts with
facebook to analyze foreign social media
manipulation
he says the trolls in 2016 mainly
created group accounts
but in 2020 peace data's trolls got more
personal
they had profile pictures that were
generated by artificial intelligence
they then had a number of accounts
across facebook and twitter and linkedin
and what they were doing was they were
hiring real people
authentic freelancers to write content
for them and so this does a few things
for them
it does sort of separate russia
from the direct influence operation in a
way that might make it harder to track
harder to identify
and it also leads to organic content in
some ways that
seems more real seems more authentic
because it's being written by a native
english speaker who knows about american
politics
the russian embassy in washington dc
said facebook's allegations are
anti-russia propaganda
facebook twitter and linkedin took down
accounts and pages linked to piece data
the website was eventually closed in
total the site
actually had a very small following
overall the traffic seems to have
not reaped the levels that we saw in
2016 but
that might only be a small
representation of all the websites out
there that russia or anyone else is
using
to try to influence american voters and
so if we can understand the tactics
i think that helps us be on alert for
similar kind of behavior
that might be on the platforms after the
exposure of peace data another website
which
was exposed which was called naebc which
posed as a far-right white supremacist
site was behaving in very much the same
way
hiring unwitting freelancers to write
for it
the hacks have also evolved in september
microsoft said it detected activity from
the same russian hackers who were behind
the attacks on the democratic campaign
in 2016.
the software giants at this time the
hackers had new reconnaissance tools
instead of emailing malicious links to
steal passwords they deployed password
sprays
which essentially guesses passwords with
multiple automated attempts
microsoft said most of the cyber attacks
weren't successful
the russian embassy in washington dc
denied microsoft's allegations
the conspiracy of russian military
realizing the threat this year
multiple u.s security agencies are
working together to share intelligence
with social media platforms
a senate investigation found that u.s
tech giants helped spread misinformation
during the 2016 election
and lawmakers pushed the companies to
better coordinate heading into 2016 the
idea of cooperating on something like
election interference was just not
happening
this was just essentially after the
edward snowden leaks of
surveillance secrets from the national
security agency
which really increased tensions between
silicon valley
and the government despite the team
effort it's still difficult to publicize
russian activities and not create
confusion
officials and companies are constantly
grappling with the challenge of
informing the public about foreign
interference without
being overly alarmist about it and
scaring them so much that it actually
accomplishes the goal of a lot of these
foreign influence operations which is
just to sow
chaos and discord to play on the
existing tensions we have in america